think about the men that say they're
afraid to approach because of the metoo
movement
I mean that's a very real thing like I
live in Brazil that stuff's not really
going on over there yet but in the
western Nations it's a really bad thing
I just did a video on my Channel about
like in Scotland if you're talking about
like a sexual conquest and a woman over
here is you can be sent to jail you can
be sent to jail yeah it's like a new
thing why yeah and in England too like I
I correct me if I'm wrong but like if
you like cat call girl on the street you
can get in trouble now right you can
Google it I don't know I'm pretty sure
that like yeah but it depends like it'll
have to be something like
I don't know it depends they won't
arrest you they won't irresistible
offenses yeah it does it does it says
this legislation well this legis wait
this led this legislation will criminal
criminalize Acts including cat calling
and making offensive gestures and
walking too closely behind something at
night yes